en 2006 vladimir vote qui a reçu la
médaille fields quatre ans plus tôt
introduit un tout nouvel axiome des
mathématiques
cet axiome l axiome du nid valence de
façon grossière l'action d'uni valence
postule l'existence d'une fonction qui à
partir d'une preuve de l'équivalence
entre deux types construit une preuve de
leur égalité et la raison pour laquelle
cet axiome est absolument génial c'est
parce qu'il permet de faire des calculs
domoto pis sans avoir à introduire les
notions de variétés différentiel ni même
la notion de nombre réel et beaucoup de
gros mots et je ne vous garantit pas que
vous comprendrez tout d'ici la fin de
cette vidéo
cependant pour ce dernier épisode de la
série sur l'infini j'aimerais quand même
bien essayer de vous faire sentir le
lien entre la théorie aux motos pic des
types et la théorie de l'houmeau topi
dont on a parlé dans l'épisode serait
aux lectures de poincaré et dans
l'épisode hardcore sur les groupes
domoto pis et pour cela on va
s'intéresser à quelque chose d'apparence
très simple on va se demander comment
construire de façon constructive le type
d entier relatif
oui parce que si vous avez suivi des
cours de mathématiques post bac
vous avez sans doute appris que
l'ensemble des entiers relatif et
l'ensemble des classes d'équivalence sur
l'ensemble des perles entiers naturels
comme l'on ait parlé dans l'épisode
hardcore que voici
sauf que ça c'est pas très constructif
et c'est pas très intuitif non plus mais
du coup quelle est la bonne intuition
des antilles relatifs et comment peut-on
la formaliser et bien je sais pas pour
vous mais un truc qui m'a beaucoup aidé
quand j'étais gamin pour visualiser ces
anti relatif c'est l'analogie de
l'ascenseur par exemple lentilles
relatif - c'est ce qu'on obtient ce que
l'on rentre dans l'ascenseur au
rez-de-chaussée à l'état zéro et que
l'on descend d'un étage et bien plus
généralement j'aime penser avec un
nombre entier relatif c'est ce qu'on
obtient lorsque l'on rentre dans un
censeur au rez-de-chaussée et que l'on
tous que l'on descend d'un certain
nombre d'états
du coup on va définir le type z
ascenseurs des entiers relative comme
étant un type avec trois constructeurs
tout d'abord il ya le constructeur de
l'état zéro ensuite comme pour les anti
naturel on peut monter vers le haut avec
un constructeur que je vais noté flèche
vers le haut flèche vers le haut et donc
une fonction qui à partir d'un entier
relatifs construit un autre chantier
relatif intuitivement au dessus enfin
dans un ascenseur on peut aussi
descendre ce qui correspond à un
constructeur flèche vers le bas super on
peut maintenant accéder à tous les
étages
vous voyez le problème
le problème survient lorsque l'on monte
d'un étage puis on descend normalement
devrait revenir au même étage autrement
dit la flèche vers le haut suivie de
flèche vers le bas devra revenir à ne
rien faire et de même vers le bas puis
vers le haut
devra revenir à ne rien faire sauf qu'à
priori jusque là rien de ce que l'on a
défini ne permet de prouver que c'est
bien le cas pour notre type z à ce
penseur des antilles est relatif et bien
ce qui est vraiment trop cool en théorie
aux motos pic des types c'est qu'on peut
s'autoriser à introduire nos propres
égalité entre des éléments du type z
ascenseur que l'on définit du coup on va
introduire des constructeurs d'égalité
qui vont nous permettre de construire
des profs d'égalité de la forme au bas
appliqué à m est égal à haine pour tout
n 2 et d'ascenseurs autrement dit il n'a
une fonction idées au bas qui pour tout
end à z donne une preuve de obama n est
égal à l est de même on a une fonction
l'idée bao qui est une fonction qui a
tout n appartenant à z ascenseur donne
une preuve que baho de haine est égal à
elle peut maintenant prouver l'égalité
entre au bas oha piqué à 0 et au
appliqué à zéro alors très clairement il
ne s'agira pas d'une égalité
définitionnelle puisque par définition
ces objets sont construit différemment
cependant on peut en trouver l'égalité
propositionnelle en fait si vous y
réfléchissez il ya même deux manières de
se faire son élimine les deux premières
flèches à l'aide de la preuve idée de
oba appliqué à ou 2 0 soit on élimine
les deux dernières flèches à l'aide
notamment de la preuve idée de baho
appliquée 0 on a là en fait de preuves
différente du fait que obama aux
appliques et 0 est égale à o appliqué à
0 pour comprendre ce qui se passe on
peut faire un dessin va représenter
chaque construction par un point donc
par exemple aux deux héros est un point
et houba aux deux héros est un autre
point maintenant une égalité qui me dit
qu'au bas oha piquée 1-0 est égale à o 2
correspond à une flèche qui va de oba
aux deux héros vert aux 2 0 et comme on
avait deux preuves différentes
on va avoir deux flèches différentes qui
vont aller de oba aux 2,0 à eau 2 0 en
utilisant maintenant les propriétés de
l'égalité propositionnelle en théorie de
type on va pouvoir inverser une des deux
flèches puis conques athénée les deux
flèches de sorte à obtenir une boucle
qui va de aux deux héros vert aux 2 0 et
on a envie de dire que cette boucle de
haut de 0,20 euro 2 0 n'est pas la
boucle trivial qui correspondrait à
rester sur aux deux héros bien ce qui
est fascinant c'est que cette notion est
très très très semblable à la notion de
boucle non contractile en théorie de
l'omo topi dont j'avais parlé dans cet
épisode hardcore en fait la ressemblance
est si frappante qu'elle nous suggère
une nouvelle définition du cercle
accrochez-vous cette définition n'a a
priori rien à voir avec ce que vous
croyez savoir du cercle en théorie aux
motos pic des types ont défini le cercle
à partir de deux constructeurs
le premier constructeur va construire un
point du cercle donc ça est un
constructeur qui n'a aucun argument on
va noter sa base qui est du coup un
élément du type cercle et on va aussi
avoir un constructeur d'égalité entre la
base et elle même on a donc deuxième
constructeur qui construit une boucle de
la base vers la basse et c'est tout on
vient de définir le cercle étrange non
est ce n'est pas un cercle comme on en a
l'habitude
ce n'est pas un cercle jaune métriques
il n'y a pas de notion de distance et il
n'a qu'un seul point s1 est en fait un
cercle au mot topic et non pas
géométriques dans la mesure où ce qui va
nous intéresser par rapport à s1
ce sont les hommes autopista dire ces
histoires de boucles et ça ça peut
paraître bizarre mais la recherche
moderne en géométrie
cherche quand même souvent à étudier et
boucle indépendamment de la structure
géométrique des variétés géométriques
que l'on étudie et bien c'est justement
ça qui est fou en théorie on note au pic
des types la théorie aux motos pic des
types nous permet d'étudier les homos
topi des objets sans avoir à se soucier
des détails géométrique de ces objets
ainsi de la même façon on peut définir
dans la théorie aux motos pic des types
la sphère homo topic s2 deux dimensions
2 celle qui correspond à la surface de
la terre
là encore la définition est étonnamment
succinct kt resf rs 2 à deux
constructeurs
le premier construit un élément base de
s2 rappelant que l'on a alors une preuve
trivial qui ont des couilles qui est la
preuve
réflexion de base prouve que base était
à la base et bien le second constructeur
de s2 construit une preuve non trivial
de l'égalité entre les preuves trivial
autrement dit il construit surface qui
est un objet de réflexion base est égal
à réflexion base oui je sais c'est très
dur intuit et tout ça mais ce qui va
être génial c'est que l'épreuve
d'égalité entre d égalité à l'intérieur
de hesse deux veaux se comporter comme
des groupes domoto pi2 s2 pour mieux
comprendre d'où ça revenons-en cercle
intuitivement on a envie de dire que
l'ensemble des books qui vont de la base
du cercle à lui-même vont être des
boucles qui correspondent soit à ne rien
faire soit effectuer la boucle qui nous
est donnée par le constructeur boucle
soit effectué cette boucle deux fois
soit effectué cette boucle trois fois
quatre fois ainsi de suite
voire même à aller faire la boucle dans
l'autre sens donc moins une fois ou
moins deux fois au moins trois fois et
ainsi de suite
intuitivement donc ce qui va
caractériser une boucle du cercle va
être l'exposant qui va être associé
nombre de fois que la boucle est
parcourue intuitivement donc l'ensemble
des boucles du cercle peut être
isomorphe âge ensemble des sentiers
relatif z
et en effet en moto pis classique puis 1
2s c'est à dire le groupe fondamentale
du cercle l'ensemble des boucles dans le
cercle va être isomorphe à l'ensemble
des entiers relatif
est ce que c'est encore le cas en
théorie des types nos intérêts des types
il n'est pas possible de prouver que la
boucle qui a été construite va être
distincte de la preuve
trivial réflexion de base qui est un
élément de base égale base qui
correspond à dire qu'on ne bouge pas de
la bassée le chemin trivial du coup en
théorie des types il n'est pas possible
non plus de prouver que le type base
égale base et iso mois au type d entier
relatif et c'est là qu'intervient
maximum du niveau lance de vladimir vos
votes ce qui en vertu de l'uni valence
il devient maintenant possible en
théorie dite homo topic du coût des
types de prouver que pi 1 2s 1
le groupe fondamentale du cercle est
égal au type des antilles est relatif
malheureusement là les détails sont
beaucoup beaucoup trop compliqué pour
qu'on puisse les aborder dans un épisode
st sour a les mêmes dans un épisode
hardcore de cette chaîne mais pour les
ultra hardcore parmi vous sachez que
j'ai écrit une série de trois billets de
blogs sur mon blog en anglais où je veux
bien plus en détails et je présente
entamant une preuve approximative
quasiment complète du fait que bien des
saints est égal à z
quoi qu'il en soit ce qui est vraiment
remarquable c'est que vos votes ce qui a
permis aux chercheurs en théorie de
l'omo topi d'étudier leurs objets au
sein d'une théorie beaucoup plus propre
beaucoup plus élémentaire est beaucoup
plus constructive que la théoriser
d'accès depuis la théorie aux motos pic
des types a été en cause et dans un
logiciel appelé coque donc dans coke
vous pouvez écrire votre suite de
construction d'objets et ce qui est
génial c'est que vous pouvez laisser
l'ordinateur vérifier la validité de vos
preuves
bref il me semble que c'est peut-être ça
le futur des mathématiques
ce sera peut-être un jeu de construction
sur un ordinateur ultra fiable
ou l'axiom du nid valence de vos votes
ce qui est le formalisme de la théorie
aux motos pic des types seront les
fontes mois la dernière fois on a parlé
de la théorie des types et y en a pas
mal par mais vous qui ont vu le lien
entre la théorie des types et la théorie
du lambda calcul fait la norme des
calculs c'est une théorie qui a été
inventé par alonso church même époque
que turine en fait churchill turing
travailler sur deux choses complètement
disjointes mais qui en fait sont issues
of dans le cas il s'agit d'une
construction de tout ce qui peut être
construit de manière constructive 1936
c'est une année est vachement important
pour l'informatique et les théories
constructive des mathématiques est en
fait la deuxième section du premier
chapitre de ce bouquin sont que première
sachant que la première section du
premier chapitre de ce bouquin parle de
la relation 20 théorie des débits la
théorie des ensembles donc la deuxième
section de ce premier chapitre c'est
vraiment là où le livre où commence
vraiment que ça parle des fonctions et
ça utilise le lanta calcul pour définir
les fonctions
donc en fait la théorie des types je
dirais qu'on peut voir ça comme une
façon de bien structurer la théorie du
landas calcul d'alonso church il ya
notamment un super commentaires de
pierre massias qui fait le lien entre la
manière dont on a construit les langages
de programmation orienté objet partir
des langages beaucoup plus fondamentaux
les langages beaucoup plus rassembleur
oussékine beaucoup plus proche de ce qui
se passe physiquement sur votre
ordinateur
ces langages à sont un petit peu le long
d'un calcul et la théorie des types
c'est un peu un langage plus haut niveau
qui est capable de faire tout ce que ce
qu'on est capable de faire un niveau
plus bas mais qui fait ça de façon
beaucoup plus jolie beaucoup plus
structuré plus
agréable notamment pour les
mathématiciens donc fins qu'il n'est pas
trop faux de dire que la théorie des
types et un joli vernissage sur les
théories constructive très fondamentales
comme la machine de turing ou la théorie
du lambda calcul pour en savoir plus je
vous invite vraiment à lire juste que
les commentaires de la vidéo précédente
il ya beaucoup de commentaires de très
très grande qualité
open mind ajoute aussi qu il y a deux
autres façons de parler des
mathématiques as-tu sioniste en
utilisant notamment la théorie des
catégorique et bloup constructif déjà
que la théorie des ensembles en fait on
peut voir un type comme une
généralisation des catégories dansant
sous une catégorie on a des objets et
des biens entre ses objets qu'on appelle
des morphisme et certaines propriétés
que doivent satisfaire les morphisme
notamment la concaténation des chemins
on peut voir un type dans la théorie des
types comme une structure où il ya aussi
ces chemins comme j'en ai parlé dans
cette vidéo
et ça c'est d'autant plus vrai en
théorie aux motos pic l'équipe d'eire
est en fait en théorie aux motos pic des
tipis elle me ment encore plus de
structure puisqu'il ya des structures
pour d égalité entre d égalité donc son
appel des structures de plus grande
dimension et donc en un certain sens en
théorie aux motos pic des types plus de
structures à l'intérieur de chaque type
en fait on parle d'un fini groupe aux
ide et ça a des liens encore une fois
avec des histoires de géométrie ou de
structures qui ont déjà été utilisés par
les mathématiciens ou par stéphane
leroux enfin nous fait l'objection que
la mécanique quantique a priori et
aléatoire elle a quelque chose de très
rare et notamment dans l'effondrement de
fonctions monde alors que les machine de
turing quelque chose de très
déterministe du coup il semblerait que
notre univers n'est pas une machine à
tuer nous n'est pas si minable par une
machine naturelle
alors il ya beaucoup d'objections
possible en fait à ce coup cela le
diable est dans les détails
la première la plus simple à mon sens
c'est tout simplement dire que la
mécanique quantique n'est qu'un modèle
de notre univers et en particulier
l'aspect aléatoire de la mécanique
quantique a priori bon ça sert d'être
assez solide mais ce n'est pas encore
complètement garanti notamment y ait
encore des théories de variables cachées
nom local qui pourrait rétablir le
déterminisme de la théorie il ya
notamment la théorie beau mienne qui en
parler je vous invite à le voir cette
vidéo de looking glass universe ou cette
vidéo de pub est spécial pour en savoir
plus à ce sujet mme notre façon
d'objecter à soi c'est de considérer des
machines naturel qu'un petit peu
différente par exemple les machines
turing qui à chaque instant du temps
prennent une variable aléatoire et pour
faire un calcul et du coup elles ont un
calcul marco bien aléatoire marco vient
ça veut dire aléatoire mais qu'il prend
quand même en compte l'instar d'un stand
présents pour voir déterminer le futur
ou encore on pourrait modifier un petit
peu le concept de machine de turing est
parlé par exemple de machine de turing
quantique
bref tout ça pour dire que c'est
vraiment pas évident de savoir si
l'univers est une machine de tueurs mais
jamais un orage la traite pas si vite
que ça
l'hypothèse selon laquelle notre univers
peut être simulé par une machine de
turing s'agit d'une pub l'hypothèse
réfutable d'ailleurs si vous arrivez à
résoudre le problème de la avec une
certaines machines physiques que vous
pouvez construire alors on saura que les
thèses de church turing est fausse et là
je vous conseille des vidéos de scott
aronson qui est un des grands experts du
domaine et qui parle très très bien de
cette question et j'espère que les
allées mais cette vidéo à voir c'est pas
tout à fait finie sur l'infini puisque
je vous prépare un épisode accord pour
jeudi sur la théorie des types notamment
j'ai envie de vous parler de l'égalité
propositionnelle
l'entrée des types qui est vraiment le
concept difficile important fascinant
qui ne marche
incroyablement bien et là où beaucoup de
mystères se cache et puis la semaine
prochaine on va commencer une nouvelle
série de vidéos
je pense que c'est vraiment cool ce sera
beaucoup plus grand public
le thème de cette série bas je voulais
couvrir et la semaine prochaine mais ce
qui est vrai qu'ils ont déjà deviné rien
si vous voulez savoir lisez les
commentaires de la vidéo précédent si
vous avez aimé cet épisode penser à la
ligue et à le commenter à le partager
pensez à vous abonner conjectures
épisode merci aussi performants et
j'espère que vous verrez la prochaine
fois
[Musique]